ja er gilt als Talent auf der linken
Seite ja endlich ein Fußballspieler wenn
er den Titel gelesen habt dann wisst ihr
auch und ihr habt ihn gelesen wer kommt
Marcel Jansen ich freue mich riesig er
wird natürlich über Fußball reden wobei
wir werden sicherlich wach simpel und er
wird über ein sehr spannendes Projekt
reden nämlich ein neues Pokerportal und
da geht es nicht darum die Leute
möglichst effektiv abzuzocken sondern es
wird für einen guten Zweck gespielt und
da sind einige prominente nicht nur
Fußballer dabei darüber und noch viel
mehr reden wir und ihr seid natürlich
auch wieder dran und könnt eure Fragen
stellen
was habe ich gesagt seit kreativ
natürlich am besten als Video Frage
Infotext lesen ja und dann kann
eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen ich
drück die Daumen und Marcel Jansen auch